also tonight republicans on capitol hill
they're demanding that joe biden do more
to [ __ ] putin cut off his oil exports
which is how he's funding this invasion
republican congresswoman victoria sparts
who was born in ukraine says this is
more than a war this is genocide take a
look
this is not a war
this is a genocide
of the ukrainian people
by a crazy man i'll tell you a personal
story i have
my grandma she's 95 she is right now in
the city of chernyhiv and her daughter
told her
they came into village with a heavy
machine gun
killed almost every person in that
village and they're killing
women and children
they do
during the bombs vacuum bombs carpet
bombs they i mean they are
using illegal weapons and i can tell you
one thing if we don't stop him there
he is not going to stop
joe biden are you listening we certainly
did see that passion did not see that
passion from biden last night at the
state of the union here now is
congresswoman from indiana's fifth
district victoria sparts is with us um
you were born in ukraine
our prayers are with your fellow
countrymen at the time them and and i'm
sure you probably still have family and
friends there
um you're watching all of this unfold
i would argue that joe biden's economic
and energy policies pushed europe
right into the hands of vladimir putin
and they became dependent on gas and oil
and i would argue that by america
importing energy oil
167 167
000 barrels a day
from russia alone
and europe so dependent on russia for
the lifeblood of their economy that's a
big factor in all of this
uh is there a short-term solution to cut
off the money supply to vladimir putin
thank you sean for having me no doubt
energy security is number one security
issues and unfortunately we have too
many people
that live in the utopian ideas hopefully
they change their mind that the biggest
threat is the climate change right now
because we have much bigger problems
right now and have lack of common sense
we have lack of common sense in europe
but we also have lack of common sense in
our country and now it created stability
blood instability bloodshed and a lot of
problems so we need to be smarter and i
think you know the president need to
understand if we want to tip the scale
and make really president putin listen
to us the most effective way to do it is
stop financing his war because you know
when i met with germans and i told them
you know i'm very disappointed in you
and they said victoria you know no
importing a lot of oil too
and to tell you the truth i didn't have
an answer for that because it was true
and it's just disgrace that we're doing
that
victoria let me ask you this question um
we're told
that putin sent in
400 mercenaries with the goal of killing
your pr the president of ukraine uh
zielinski
now the question is there was there was
one report that said that there might
have been russian intelligence officials
that tipped off zielinski
of what their operation was all about
and may have even saved his life do you
believe that there are russians that are
willing to step up and stand out against
vladimir putin uh not wanting to be a
part of a modern-day mass slaughter
well and i think there is another
problem and you know
actually it used to be we always had
bandits you know in former soviet union
time actually grew up in soviet union
but they were not part of the government
now president putin made chechnya mafia
sitting in offices next to him and
threatening russians and i think a lot
of people even in his police force and
do not like that because these people
are lawless and he's using them to
suppress russian people and everyone
else so i wouldn't be surprised if there
is some
in dissatisfaction in the police force
and among his people you know in the
tools and mechanisms he's using and
that's what he was trying to do in
ukraine he installed president who was a
former criminal
to get in and run this country with the
criminal way and ukrainians said no
enough is enough
they took him down
he sent you know 100
he sent police force they killed 100
people and guess what millions show up
next day now he send an army because he
want to teach them a lesson
and destroy them because they cannot be
suppressed but i think he underestimates
ukrainians these people are going to
fight and these people are going to win
but the loss can be significant
if putin is the one responsible every
dead
man woman and child
in your former country of ukraine
the blood is on his hands
and if somebody is able around him in
his inner circle to take him out by
whatever means necessary doesn't matter
to me
if they're able to wouldn't that send a
message to every two-bit uh wannabe
dictator in the world that you're next
if you have territorial ambitions
as vladimir putin does
well i mean
you know
the threat is always like there a lot of
change of regime and russian happen like
that through history so i think any
dictator always you don't think a
dictator would think twice about
invading an innocent country if that's
the net result
well unfortunately i wish dictators
would have think because this is
irrational and this is sad what is
happening you know but um you know we
also probably should have done a better
job dealing with him more proactively
not reactively because he was very clear
and i don't know if you remember sean a
few years ago he was on fox news and he
was talking about that that you don't
take me seriously guy but i'm not trying
to waste my money to defend i'm going to
go on a fence and develop to come off to
you and i think that was a clear message
so we need to take people like that
seriously but now we need to stop this
bloodshed because a lot of people are
going to kill and exercise some
leadership congresswoman our prayers are
with the ukrainian people thank you for
being with us tonight and we appreciate
it